seis jóvenes contra el operador de la
planta nuclear de fukushima en el
momento del desastre nuclear en 2011
estuvieron expuestos a la radiación y
posteriormente desarrollaron cáncer de
tiroides infantil hogar siempre quise
ser una mujer de carrera trabajando
fuerte en tokio pero me diagnosticaron
cáncer y todavía me siento mal después
de la cirugía desde entonces estoy en
una condición en la que tengo que
priorizar mi salud por encima de todo
las 6 personas que tenían entre 6 y 16
años en el momento del accidente fueron
diagnosticadas con cáncer de tiroides
entre 2012 y 2018 exigen que tokyo
electric power company holdings pague un
total de 54 millones de dólares en
compensación en esta primera demanda
colectiva a los demandantes buscan que
el tribunal ayude a descubrir la
correlación que hay entre el cáncer y la
radiación que se filtró de la planta
1a el cáncer de tiroides es una
enfermedad rara que sólo una década un
millón de personas contrae en promedio
como el número de niños en fukushima es
de alrededor de 30.000 sólo una persona
lo contraería cada pocos años
después del desastre nuclear
266 personas contrajeron cáncer en
fukushima
esta hipótesis es descartada hasta ahora
por el panel de expertos encargado por
el gobierno en la prefectura de
fukushima el 11 de marzo de 2011 un
terremoto de magnitud 9 a 130 km de la
costa de la ciudad de sendai causó un
posterior tsunami con olas de 15 metros
de altura que embistió la planta nuclear
de fukushima el desastre dejó alrededor
de 18.500 personas muertas o
desaparecidas la mayoría por el tsunami
la fusión nuclear en la planta de
fukushima fue el peor accidente de este
tipo desde el desastre de chernóbil en
1986 después del cual se detectaron un
mayor número de cáncer de tiroides tras
casi 11 años los administradores de la
planta aún debaten qué hacer con las
aguas residuales contaminadas